what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
okay so we are finally getting into the
century series and initially I plan on
doing all five issues at once but
there's a lot of explanation to do here
so we cannot do all five issues at once
if we did we would end up with like a 45
minute long video so this century man
it's so good to see the century finally
get his own solo series back hopefully
it lasts for a while we have no idea how
long it'll last the century is one of
those weird characters people love the
powers of the century they hate the way
this century is written so it's kind of
weird when it comes to that whole thing
I do was a point where he was like a
backup character of Civil War
a guy who fought the Incredible Hulk to
his standstill like fights Wolverine and
then gets overpowered explain that one
to me so the cool thing about this is
that this initially picked up with
Robert Reynolds kind of musing about
himself to like his three distinctive
personalities and this is an important
thing because while the century has
appeared a lot in Marvel Comics since
Paul genius and J Lee's original run in
2004 a lot of people he's still pretty
obscure and when it comes to Robert
Reynolds
he suffers from three personalities
there's the void there's the Sentry
itself and then there's Robert Reynolds
and oftentimes he'll talk about all
three personalities he'll refer to
himself you refer to the century and
then we refer to the void but the voids
the one that he's the most afraid of and
that's what he talks about here he talks
about how there's just Robert Reynolds
the everyday average guy the dude who's
just there and then he talked about the
Sentry who is his superhero counterpart
his other personality with all using all
these crazy powers and then the void
being the one that he's most afraid of
now for those of you guys who never read
the old Paul Jenkins daily run which you
guys need to it's incredibly good it's
almost impossible to get your hands on
now and the original story is the idea
was you had Captain America who was the
first super soldier and after he was
frozen in ice and everybody thought that
he died it was like a mad dash to create
new super soldiers the idea was that
there was a a professor who was working
on a Super Soldier Serum there was a
thousand times more powerful than the
one that gave Captain America his
abilities and so when Robert Reynolds
took that serum and ingested it it moved
his molecules like a head like an
instant ahead of the current time stream
what is just Marvel's way of saying like
it's our reason for why he can do
anything he wants to do now the reason
why that explanation was given back in
2000 is because originally the Sentry
was presented to Marvel readers as a
lost character from the old Stanley Jack
Kirby stories that maybe was a character
they were messing around with and never
did anything with and then now he was
recently discovered and his stories are
being published it was actually pretty
smart nowadays it would never work but
at that point in time when the internet
was still fairly new
I was super popular and it worked really
well it tricked me it works really
really well
but the fact remains here that following
this Robert riddles you end up having a
scenario where this being called the
void would show up and just start
attacking things and would like tear
stuff up and it was one point with a
void like like eradicated a huge section
of New York and then towards the end of
the story you end up finding out Robert
Reynolds is actually the void himself
and so what they did is Doctor Strange
and Reed Richards and a sentry himself
they created this device it would
basically consistently emit a pulse that
would wipe the minds of everybody on
earth of the centuries knowledge if no
one remembered he existed including
Robert Reynolds himself he couldn't turn
it into this century and if he couldn't
turn into the century the void couldn't
come back and so it was kind of a way to
keep everything hid now of course that
goes into the actual century story
itself by Paulding his and Jay Lee the
century returns and all I kind of cool
stuff but we'll get into some of those
things as we go through this but in this
moment what we end up finding out is
that with Robert Reynolds fear of the of
the void returning after becoming the
century what he needed was an outlet and
so what this does is it comes hot off
the heels of of Loki's sorcerer supreme
now flow the guys should ever read that
story Loki sorcerer supreme was a recent
story that was done in Marvel and it
kind of brought in the idea of what if
Loki took all the powers of dr. strange
and what Doctor Strange ended up doing
was actually reaching out and contacting
Robert Reynolds for the purpose of
unleashing the void on Loki which worked
and the void absolutely destroyed him
which made sense because the void killed
Loki during the events of siege on
Asgard
so if Loki was terrified of it and so
that sort in response to that Loki
basically ends up getting like pummeled
all the pieces and any yeah like that's
that that's kind of it now following
that this surgery was there and so what
we end up learning is the centuries
basically in this kind of other reality
more or less like this pocket universe
that was that was created for him we're
not told right off the bat that's the
case instead we end up having this
sentry picking up with clock now clock
was the artificial intelligence that
Robert Reynolds used it was kind of like
his own version like it's a little robot
thing his own little companion that
would follow him around and what this
did is it would it would basically be
like his living autonomous robot that
would function according to its own
wishes and wants but would help out
century--and like given little bits of
advice and different things like that
but with him fighting in the city we end
up finding out that what the void has
done is conjured like these shadow
beings he's kind of shadow puppets and
is using them to attack the city not
only that the roster of the century has
been expanded to bring back scalp but
then also introduced Jenny a centrist
which is a character this wholly new
we've never seen her before
she's never existed here now scout again
kind of you know like we said we jump
back to the old Paul Jean is in jail II
think Scout was originally this
sidekick of the century who was
originally this young kid who would
fight alongside Robert Reynolds and the
two of them would do their own thing now
there came a point when Scout lost his
arm and had to retire because the void
took it the void literally like
destroyed his arm and it's kind of this
weird little thing is kind of a really
sad moment kind of a bittersweet moment
when you go and you read the century and
then you get towards the end and Scout
seems to remember everything but it's
kind of a cool thing because Scouts
basically return fighting alongside the
century you've got watchdog which is the
sentries dog and then of course
centrists which is Jenny and and it's
kind of cool to see this whole thing go
down but with them fighting alongside
each other these puppets are dealt with
like quick fast and in a hurry but the
void like what what uh what what
cocktails the century is that the void
is at the moon and the sentries response
is well then we'll go to the moon and
we'll fight we'll fight the void but
then in turn the Neil Clark says no it's
he's not he's not on the moon he's
inside the moon and so the century
literally punches the moon in half in
order to get to the void which is kind
of crazy this century punches the moon
in half which is well within his powers
I mean Jeff Lemire is not cooking the
books here that's entirely possible for
the century to do him he's done stuff
like that before and then very
reminiscent and a lot of you guys will
probably remember this very reminiscent
to New Avengers when you have a Elektra
who takes down the the raft the
supervillain prison uh you end up having
this this scenario where like carnage
gets out and the century like rips
carnage in half and that's what happens
here like it's actually kind of a cool
little thing when he tears the void in
half literally rips his head off and the
century ends up winning now right off
the bat for those people who are
familiar with the century that shouldn't
be the case rubber riddles should not be
able to defeat the void that readily he
never has he never will he's always that
scared but the void is just that
powerful and that's one thing to keep in
mind here there is a kind of hierarchy
when it comes to power levels among like
this century personas right you have
Robert Reynolds who's like a baseline
human up from him you have this century
and then from the century you have the
void now in reality the century and void
have the exact same power the difference
is that the void doesn't hold back
and so century like puts blocks in place
and doesn't allow as a power his power
to run on you know run completely
uncontrolled and in without any real
checks and balances but at the same time
he's also afraid if he does let his
power loose in his totality it would
lead to the to the arrival of the void
the void would emerge he'd end up
falling to his darker half and all hell
would break loose and so this century is
weaker than the void but really by
choice as opposed to you know physical
or hard circumstance and so with the
void being defeated the centuries kind
of like hate like you know I fixed the
moon everything's go back to normal and
we end up finding out this world
basically heals itself it's a looping
pattern not only that you have
and you have you have watchdog and you
have centrist who are watching him go
and it's basically this injury saying
I'll be back here in a little while and
so basically this seems to be like an
artificial world because they literally
say but when you come back the boy to be
back and he's like yeah and we'll defeat
him again that's what we do but then we
jump back into the real world and we end
up finding out that what Robert Reynolds
has been doing is jumping into this kind
of pocket dimension created for him by
dr. strange and from the time he leaves
until we're really like like from the
from time he leaves that universe the
watch starts he's got 24 hours in order
to be able to jump back in there again
and it's kind of a cool scenario because
it's not really something we've seen
before what this does is put on the
indication that Robert Reynolds cannot
control this century and then again
that's new you know Robert Reynolds has
always been able to control this century
persona
it's the void he can't control and avoid
these the most afraid of but again with
this century comes the bling and so we
end up following Robert is he's
literally going through and looking at
his watch and keeping keeping track of
time going through as his morning
routine all that kind of good stuff and
he ends up working at a diner where of
course we have Scout and then we have
Ginny and so Ginny being in that
artificial world is just a construct of
his imagination I'm an intern she fights
as the centrist you know kind of as a
sidekick and so is it's kind of crazy
because you also end up having Scout who
holds a lot of a lot of anger towards
Robert Reynolds which again is something
that we're not really used to Scott's
been gone for a long long time so Jeff
Lemire has kind of got a clean slate
there's whatever you know whatever Paul
geing isn't J Lee did and then what have
a couple stories he appeared and after
that but nothing was ever really
solidified he's no Captain America he's
not Iron Man or Thor and you know I
guess Odin son or anything like that
he's just a character who's there that
people that even the most die-hard
sentry fans may or may not be aware of
and so when you go into this he's got 14
hours left in the day he ends up heading
back home only to be intercepted by
misty Knight and a handful of people now
misty Knight is what I call in male
comics a person who free floats misty
Knight originally made her debut as part
of Heroes for Hire back in the old
really like the old old days you know
with Luke Cage and iron fist and then of
course you took over and launched the
new Heroes for Hire as part of Civil War
and she's had been kind of floating
around ever since here she's part of
what appears to become a governmental
organization and the way this
organization works or at least you know
how it seems to function is as part of
the aberrant Crimes Division
basically like those crazy individuals
who were out there this century and
that's one thing to keep in mind the
century has been classified over and
over and over again and like the shield
intelligence files and like the 198 and
all these have been one shots and things
that mama puts out is like an
omega-level threat meaning he
the equivalent of an omega-level mutant
but he's not a mutant but he is a
planetary threat and so constantly
keeping an eye on him is something that
government seems to be doing now more so
than ever because the century has
returned but the idea is we're watching
you we're keeping an eye on you and
truth Jeff Lemire throws this in there
just for the sake of saying here you
know here's the thing going on in the
background and that's really about it
but with Robert Reynolds running back up
to his house here running back up to his
room and then going to access his his
device we end up finding out that is
basically missing and when that happens
somebody else seems to have gotten ahold
of it the reason why is because the door
to century world opens up scout and
watchdog are there and then in turn this
person kills a dog and they kill Scouts
which is kind of like okay who has
control of sentry world and like who has
the sentries powers now and so from
there you end up going into country
world proper where you have like this
person who's just kind of unleashing
hell throughout the world and centrist
is like the last person standing and she
falls quite readily and we end up
finding out this is basically cranium
now Crais do is a wholly new character
here and Jeff Lemire can get away with
that because remember when the original
sentry story came out you had side
issues you had like this century and and
you know spider-man in this century and
the Fantastic Four in this century and
The Incredible Hulk the century and the
extra man and so on and that was it
because those are the only characters
who were really like rolled into the
century story when he finally fought the
void at the end but by and large Marvel
had established in that Paul geing is in
jail e story this century had been
around for a long long time we just
hadn't heard of him before and so it's
really a way for Jeff Lemire to just
start grabbing characters and rolling
him in now cranial himself is an
absolute horse of a character and that's
a cool thing he's not a joke he's not
some small guy that you mess around with
he's pretty dangerous like his his
levels of telepathy and telekinesis are
kind of insane here and he's literally
just like wrecking everything like like
just going through and decimating
everything in its entirety now the
problem that we have to deal with here
is he's only fighting centrist at the
moment and we don't know where her
powers reside we don't know if she's
equal to the century we don't know if
she's a little less powerful we don't
know if she's like Supergirl pre-crisis
and she's more powerful but still the
fact remains here that in this instance
you know it's it's literally Robert
Reynolds realizing his device has been
stolen cranials wreaking havoc inside
this pocket dimension and then in turn
Robert riddles runs off and basically
grabs scout and says hey look man like
we have to do something here now scouts
response is one to be angry and
basically saying like so I'm the last
guy you come to like I was your sidekick
we were superheroes together and I'm the
last guy you come to now this is really
kind of Jeff Lemire riding the nature of
scouts character
into his own character itself which is
to say nobody really cared about scout
like when people think of this century
nobody ever says hey guys who do you
think would win in a fight The
Incredible Hulk or this century and
scalp nobody ever says that they just
say like The Incredible Hulk versus the
century Superman versus the century you
know asking questions that nobody could
ever really give an answer to and so
it's kind of cool there because this
century is basically like a forgotten
character and in the story he feels
forgotten because Robert riddles didn't
go to him first he contacted Tony Stark
he contacted dr. strange of course this
seems to take place around the same time
that the events of infinity wars seems
to be going on so Doctor Strange isn't
there he's in other dimensions Tony
Stark's off doing his own thing that was
kind of weird in terms of when it
actually happens but like scout feels
kind of pissed and he feels kind of
betrayed like I'm not man I'm not
Captain America I'm not dr. strange I'm
not one of your big guys up there I'm a
small guy down here at the bottom so of
course you would come to me last but the
response of Robert Reynolds is hey look
man I didn't mean for it to come off
that way let's see if we can't figure
out a way to fix another one on our own
now this is dangerous because Robert
Reynolds can do it as the century but
again with this century comes the void
that's really what Scout says well you
can't because if you do you'll you you
could potentially unleash the void on
earth and you would kill everything but
what you end up having is Robert
Reynolds who ends up taking off because
of course scout has to get back into the
kitchen and cook and when he leaves he's
basically tracked down by misty Knight
and the AC B now when this happens he's
transported to another location about
six miles below ground which is not
really it's kind of a stopgap measure
that's what did it bear in mind guys by
and large and Marvel Comics there are
characters who are just uncontrollable
they cannot be contained The Incredible
Hulk cannot be contained no matter where
you put the Incredible Hulk if you give
him enough time and he gets angry enough
he will get out the Sentry is the same
way he would just punch through it and
eventually just take off with him being
here the question is why am I here only
for us to be met with the arrival of
Tony Stark and this is cool because what
stark says is I got all of your
voicemails when you called me and you
were trying to get ahold of me I got
every single one of your voicemails but
this was a test to let you out on you
know to let you out like this this was a
test to see whether or not you could
control the century and you can't you
cannot keep the Sentry under control by
whatever manner in whatever means this
century will eventually emerge we
created a device for you that you could
basically travel into and unleash that
century energy by fighting against the
void and it's gone now so no matter what
we do somebody somewhere will have a way
to defeat you because you can't be
everywhere at once it just doesn't work
that way
especially when you're in your normal
human form and so because of this we're
keeping you here this is gonna be a way
to basically keep you safe to let you do
your own
thing to keep the void presence from
coming out but at the end of the day
Tony Stark still knows just like
everybody else if the void manifests
there's nothing they can do they're not
gonna be able to stop it because it's
just like a being it was powerful enough
to kill gods and cosmic entities
what's a prison six mile six miles below
earth and below the earth's surface
possibly gonna do to keep the void in
check and so in the end you end up
having robert riddles who says look i
need to find my device like i need to
find my device or have dr. strange and
you create a new one or something like
that but i'm not staying down here and
when Tony Stark responds by saying hey
look man I know how you feel I
understand where you're coming from but
again like I'm asking you
stop requesting to leave and the
responses of the century is I wasn't
asking you I'm telling you and literally
manifests and then just kind of takes
off but when that happens his response
is something's wrong here like I mean
I'm I'm the century but like something
else is going on something's going on in
my head and that's what we end up
basically realizing that what's been
going on is that the century is there
like like the actual center persona is
is manifested but Robert Reynolds has
been thrown back into his own mind and
inside of his own mine in this dimension
that he's been in known in this own
mindscape that he has that this guy
cranial is still running amok and so
what potentially seems to be going on
here is a create a cranial has managed
to access this century's mind and in
doing so could turn it like could
literally seize control the centuries
body and unleash absolute hell or even
worse merge with the void and become
even more powerful so it gets kind of it
gets kind of bonkers because what we end
up doing is we basically have like
Robert Reynolds who's there when crania
destroys centrist eradicate sir in ur
entirety all the time basically going on
and saying you're not real none of this
stuff is real this is all fake you know
in turn like like destroying her and
then we pick up with Scout who gets back
home only for us to find out Scouts the
one who took it Scouts the one who took
the device of the century with scout
intending to become the new sentry
himself so it's actually pretty cool
like it's pretty badass and I'm pretty
excited about it actually it's pretty
sweet but again like creo is just a guy
who's there kind of in a vegetative
state but again it seems like it's
really a way for Scout to kind of access
the mind in the century seize control of
it and then use it for his own whim
how that manifests of course we'll have
to finish the story in order to find out
but if you are new here to comment
explain make sure you guys at the sub
button to become part of the robb core
if you guys enjoyed this video make sure
you drop a like and yeah
I will catch you all later peace
[Music]